This isn't even a full word,
but can you guess which language in says?
Chances are you can thanks to that very
Spanish letter and yet hold on there.
Once upon a time. This end with the deal
day wasn't so Spanish. Take it apart.
You'll find the tail of an ordinary
mark that evolved into an extraordinary
letter.
Spain has a national hero, a really old
one, like almost a thousand years old.
They call him and see, or if feed. Look,
Spain is notorious for lifting its fees,
but out here in the western hemisphere
and even over there [inaudible] it's
[inaudible] and sit at the stuff a
good national heroes supposed to do.
He wielded a legendary weapon.
He fought cunningly for various factions,
but always kept bigger goals in mind.
He won the hearts of the peasants. Oh,
and he loved about Viet Guy.
His trusty steed one legend tells
us how they met when he was young,
super the Reno. His Godfather took
him out to pick his very own horse.
He was treated to a parade of
beautiful stallions. Go on, pick one,
the Betty Best one.
You see somehow and seed peered through
all this splendid mains and cuts side of
the most awkward horse in the
bunch. This one, I want this one,
God father couldn't believe it, but
Viet Guff for, why'd you pick that one?
Whoa buddy. At Guy. Yes. I think
his name shall be Bobby [inaudible].
He'd be a good horse.
US mean you spent centuries weaving tails
like this about your beloved said the
most epic of these epic tales is a
poem written in the 12th century.
Gunther Daimyo seed.
Some of my PsyD. Sure,
there's this older Latin history written
closer to the events, but the people,
they liked the epic poem.
That poem was preserved for us in one
single rare manuscript and if you want to
read this medieval manuscript, you need
to know old Spanish, not just Spanish,
no older Spanish,
different words with different meanings,
different spelling and pronunciation,
different grammar,
but before you can jump into any of that,
you're blocked by this
scribes handwriting.
The problem isn't really his handwriting.
He was a fine scribe, neat and tidy.
The problem is this script
is not your script. Yes.
It's the Latin Alphabet,
but even once you adjust to the letters,
there's something strange. Get your
nose close enough to smell the paper.
Actually, the big amino parchment, close
enough to see the little squiggles.
Interesting thing about parchment.
Back in the day,
scribes didn't go to the store and
pick up packs for pennies. A page.
This book making stuff was
a very expensive endeavor,
partly because of that ancient scribes.
It started coming up with ways to save
paper but keep their manuscripts. Pretty.
One trick was to make words shorter.
With hundreds of years of scrabbled
practice behind the medieval scribes had
amassed a treasure chest of symbols.
They can get fancy,
but here's a simple one
you'll see all the time.
The did DLoose what it for.
We'll look at the letters below it.
Sometimes they're shorten words.
Scribes were abbreviating everything
from sacred names to run of the mill
pronouns. When they did this though,
they left a nifty over mark as a hint.
It has a more specific use though.
Look at the words Mundo commanded and
also don't Lord and Donya lady from Latin
dominus and Damina.
The scribe could spell them out or he
could remove one consonant and write this
tittle loose on top of the letter before
it. Notice which consonant got removed.
The nasal n writing ends on top of
previous letters instead of inline isn't
something we can blame the seed for.
It had been trending for centuries
for both Latin nasals ends and ams.
Good luck getting through
too many medieval manuscripts
without it ends above.
Val's ends on top of consonants,
ends everywhere, but these ends,
we're still optional.
Take the word for year on those
which had two end side by side.
That word became Spanish
on you as a scribe.
You could take that second day in and
write it as a [inaudible] loose above the
first,
but you could just as well take the first
and have it hop on top of us or just
leave them side by side.
Over time though,
the other marks fell away and [inaudible]
the former double end was left all
alone in Spain.
Seemingly one of a kind.
Why did only this one remnant
stick around? Well, it was useful.
The other nasal marks were interchangeable
with a full on n but Latin double n
evolve to have its own
pronunciation in Spanish. Yeah.
Ania this leftover did to loose isn't
as lonely as it first seems though.
Just next door,
Portugal found this same mark,
very useful for writing nasal
valves in modern Portuguese.
They still use it not above end though,
but to mark nasal. Ah, and Oh hmm.
Hmm hmm. Oh, and here's a fact
drop to impress your friends.
The name for this mark
did to loose became delay,
which got borrowed into
English as Tilda in Spanish.
Though the day doesn't
just mean this thing,
it's the word for any special marker
diacritic including the accents.
But today's NBA isn't an end with
a funny mark on it out in Spanish.
One more change had to be made and image
change that academia Hispaniola Royal
Spanish Academy got together in the
early 17 hundreds to organize and oversee
Spanish vocabulary time to impose
some order on this language.
Their dictionary still the gold standard.
But back in 1726 to group was barely
taking a first stab at this dictionary
business with their Dick
soon audio authority.
That is now you won't find any listed
as a letter on the spines or title pages
of any of its six volumes.
But entries that start with an
ea are listed separately after n.
It's a move the academy has since fully
committed to today and it has its own
seat at the Spanish alphabet table,
middle keen say,
and it's so quintessentially Spanish
that it's become a symbol of Hispanic
culture. Here I just localize my
channel for Spain and Latin America.
You laugh, but that is how some companies
do it. So what? We're in his seat,
stay ordinary marks on parchment.
Found a way to outlast the rest of them
and become a full fledged Spanish letter.
A letter that only catches the occasional
reflection of its younger days in
scattered relatives from
not to distant lands.
Stick around for more linguistic
stories and subscribe for language.